widerstand gegen die türkische offensive
die kurden rufen um hilfe
assad schickt seine truppen ins
umkämpfte grenze grenzgebiet maßnahmen
gegen rechten terror nach dem anschlag
von halle fordert die cdu mehr
kompetenzen für die sicherheitsbehörden
und einen besseren schutz jüdischer
einrichtungen hartes urteil gegen
separatisten heftige proteste in
katalonien gegen die langen haftstrafen
für an führer der
unabhängigkeitsbewegung
nachrichten des tages heute mit petra
gerster guten abend willkommen bei den
19 uhr nachrichten die vom sport hat
wieder arbeitnehmern dabei eine stunde
am tag vor mir
der einmarsch der türkischen truppen in
den norden syriens vor einer knappen
woche hat die lage dort völlig verändert
während vorher die syrischen kurden an
der seite der amerikaner denise
bekämpften sind sie nun das ziel der
türkischen angriffe und während die
amerikaner abziehen wollten jetzt als
satz truppen in den norden vor
was die lage zuspitzt thomas konnte
erklärt sie uns genauer der nordosten
von syrien ist kurdengebiet hier wird
die türkei eine sogenannte schutzzone
einrichten
dazu hat sie vergangene woche eine
militäroffensive gestartet mehrere orte
sind mittlerweile eingenommen
durch türkische soldaten und ihre
verbündeten arabische und syrische
milizen zehntausende zivilisten fliehen
vor den kämpfen und auch das kurdische
wachpersonal zieht sich zurück aus
lagern in denen anhänger des sogenannten
islamischen staats und ernährt sind die
folge gestern entkommen hunderte
dschihadisten angeblich auch aus
gefängnissen
syriens machthaber assad truppen
geschickt einige gebiete sollen sie
schon kontrollieren
stimmt das beim stimmten sich syrische
und türkische soldaten gegenüber eine
neue gefährliche lage fragt sich wie die
internationale gemeinschaft auf diese
neue lage reagiert die eu verurteilt die
türkische offensive und fordert ihre
mitglieder auf der türkei keine neuen
waffen mehr zu liefern
das berichtet gleich stefan leifert aus
brüssel aber zuvor zeigt unser
korrespondent luk walpert was der neue
konflikt für die region bedeutet
soldaten der us armee heute bei ihrer
ankunft in teltow 30 kilometer südlich
der grenze zur türkei von arabischen
bewohnern des ortes bejubelt sie soll
den einmarsch der türken und der mit
ihnen verbündeten milizen stoppen seit
sechs tagen rücken türkische kräfte
massiv nach nordsyrien vor
nach dem abzug der us-soldaten
verhandelten die bedrängten kurdischen
milizen mit assad über militärischen
beistand wir hatten so der kurdische
kommando abdi sahin die wahl zwischen
genozid oder ausverkauf an assad
ungeachtet der jüngsten entwicklung
verlegt die türkei weiter kräfte ins
kriegsgebiet
die präsidentin erdogan und putin
stünden in engem kontakt hieß es in
moskau
erdogan selbst bekräftigte bei einem
besuch in aserbaidschan heute noch
einmal dass drohungen und kritik ihn
nicht beeindrucken unser kampf wird
weitergehen bis der endgültige sieg
errungen ist wir werden die angefangene
arbeit auf jeden fall zu ende bringen
türkische soldaten marschieren auch auf
die westlich des euphrat gelegenen stadt
man beach dort sollen bereits
assad-truppen eingetroffen seien bislang
kam es nicht zur konfrontation die
kämpfe fordern inzwischen zahlreiche
opfer unter der zivilbevölkerung genaue
angaben über die zahl von verletzten und
toten gibt es nicht aber mehr als
130.000 menschen sind auf der flucht
[Musik]
so groß die runde so groß die
hilflosigkeit in luxemburg suchen die
eu-außenminister eine antwort auf den
türkischen angriff und finden nur den
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner
ein appell der türkei keine waffen zu
liefern entscheidend ist dass wir diese
militärische invasion nicht unterstützen
durch die zulieferung weiterer waffen
das haben heute alle mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union bestätigt und das ist
das was unmittelbar wirkt kein
generelles waffenembargo keine
wirtschaftssanktionen kein ende der
beitrittsverhandlungen
die eu einigt sich auf starke worte
starke sanktionen bleiben aus unter nato
ländern geht indes die sorge um in den
krieg hineingezogen zu werden
sie wissen dass es ein artikel 5 gibt in
dem nato pakt mit der besagt für ein
land angegriffen wird müssen alle
anderen länder helfen das land zu
verteidigen stellen sich vor die die
türkei wird von serien oder alliierten
expect ich erwarte dass die türkei mit
zurückhaltung reagiert und in abstimmung
mit den anderen nato partnern damit wir
die erfolge gegen unseren gemeinsamen
feind den es nicht gefährden
eu und nato kommen heute über appelle
nicht hinaus europa bleibt in syrien
krieg auch weiterhin nur zuschauer
nach dem anschlag von halle diskutiert
die politik weiter über die konsequenzen
vorschläge reichen von mehr kompetenzen
für ermittlungsbehörden bis zu einer
beobachtung der afd
durch den verfassungsschutz am mittwoch
hatte der 27-jährige täter versucht ein
massaker in der synagoge von halle
anzurichten
als das scheiterte tötete er eine frau
und ein mann die menschen in halle
trauern weiter um die opfer fischer
berichtet innenminister holger
stahlknecht steht unter druck
es gibt viele fragen auch vorwürfe die
polizei in halle habe nicht schnell
genug auf notrufe reagiert und den täter
nach dem anschlag auf der flucht eine
stunde aus den augen verloren
die stufe ist nicht als punkerin mein
tiefster innerer empfundener dank gilt
meiner polizei unserer polizei ohne wenn
und aber
in berlin wird über die politischen
konsequenzen diskutiert weil der
mutmaßliche täter sich im internet
radikalisiert und sich dort über
messenger dienste mit gleichgesinnten
ausgetauscht hat fordert die cdu mehr
rechte für polizei und verfassungsschutz
im netz effektive überwachung von
extremistischen kommunikationsnetzwerken
möglichkeit der strafverfolgung im netz
auch ohne dass die geschädigten anzeige
erstatten
eine verbesserte analyse und auswertung
von big data
der mutmaßliche täter war auch in der
gamer szene aktiv innenminister seehofer
hatte gefordert diese plattformen für
computerspiele stärker in den blick zu
nehmen
kritik gibt es dafür aus der eigenen
partei und von der spd
das problem heißt rechtsextremismus das
heißt übrigens nicht gamer oder sonst
was diese debatte halten wir für absolut
falsch
in halle geht das gedenken weiter am
frühen abend mit einem ökumenischen
gottesdienst landesbischof kramer
predigte es sei das wunder von halle
dass die tür zur synagoge gehalten habe
aber dass zwei menschen ermordet wurden
sei die wunde die nicht so schnell
verheilen werde für die angehörigen der
opfer und für betroffene ist ein
spendenkonto eingerichtet wurden
es ist eine tradition in großbritannien
die queen eröffnet jede neue parlaments
periode mit feierlichen zeremoniell
diesmal beim 65 mal ging es besonders
prunkvoll zu königin elizabeth die
zweite verliest die regierungserklärung
von premierminister boris johnson ein
regierungsprogramm von dem völlig unklar
ist ob es so jemals umgesetzt wird denn
dafür fehlt johnson eine mehrheit im
parlament und neuwahlen stehen im raum
tja tiana zimmer meine london was war
denn das heute für eine veranstaltung im
parlament
das war eine farce das hat zwar alles so
aus wie es hier seit fast 400 jahren
aussieht wenn ein staatsoberhaupt die
regierungserklärung verleast und die
botschaft war natürlich glasklar im
königreich geht alles seinen
traditionellen gang
der premier hat alles im griff doch das
gegenteil ist der fall boris johnson hat
nicht mal eine mehrheit um die
angekündigten maßnahmen durchzusetzen
tatsächlich strebt er selbst ja
neuwahlen an und insofern war das heute
mehr eine wahlkampfrede für die
konservative partei verlesen durch die
knie
vor allem aber alles das was sonst hat
ankündigen lassen setzt voraus dass der
exit am 31 oktober stattfindet und das
ist immer noch völlig unklar
zur stunde wird in brüssel um eine
vereinbarung gerungen selbst wenn das
gelingen sollte müsste johnson diese am
samstag durch das parlament bekommen
wahrscheinlicher ist dass es wieder zu
einer verschiebung kommt möglich ist
dass johnston abgesetzt wird und
ziemlich sicher ist dass die queen schon
bald eine neue regierungserklärung
verlesen muss vielen dank für ihre
einschätzungen diana zimmermann in
london
in polen hat die regierungspartei peace
die parlamentswahl klar gewonnen
viel rückenwind für die partei also die
einige male in migrations und
justizfragen mit brüssel aneinander
geraten war
die national konservativen um parteichef
klatschen ski bekam knapp 44 prozent
die pis kann demnach mit absoluter
mehrheit im parlament weiterregieren
auf platz zwei landete die
oppositionelle liberale bürger koalition
mit gut 27 prozent mehr demokratie und
weniger korruption das hat der
parteilose juraprofessor seit den
tunesien versprochen
jetzt haben sie ihn zu ihrem neuen
staatsoberhaupt gewählt
in einer stichwahl setzte sich sei jetzt
mit mehr als 70 prozent der stimmen
gegen den medienunternehmer karoui durch
auf den straßen feierten tausende ihren
neuen präsidenten in tunesien liegt
allerdings der größte teil der macht
beim premierminister und seiner
regierung
ein urteil in spanien heute dass das
land weiter spalten könnte die vorfälle
um die es geht liegen gut zwei jahre
zurück 2017 höhepunkt der katalanischen
unabhängigkeitsbewegung die
regionalregierung ließ über eine
abspaltung kataloniens abstimmen
dabei hatte die justiz in madrid das
verboten wegen aufruhrs müssen die
meisten der anführer nun viele jahre ins
gefängnis
london/barcelona gibt es dagegen
proteste crystal hat das urteil ist kaum
ein paar stunden alt da blockieren
tausende katalanen den flughafen von
barcelona den polizisten rufen sie zu
besatzungsmacht raus hier
das geht nicht lange gut die
sicherheitsbeamten führen einige
demonstranten ab proteste auch auf
vielen straßen und bahngleisen in
katalonien wir hoffen dass die proteste
nicht nur einen tag anhalten sondern
weiter gehen und dass wir es schaffen
das ganze land lahmzulegen
es geht um diese zwölf angeklagten neun
von ihnen wurden heute wegen aufruhrs zu
neun bis 13 jahren haft verurteilt fast
alles sind ehemalige katalanische
regierungsmitglieder
sie waren vor zwei jahren an dem
gescheiterten abspaltung versuch
beteiligt der spanien in eine tiefe
krise gestürzt hatte eine entscheidung
die mit empörung zitiert wird sogar auf
englisch für die internationale presse
dieses urteil wird uns nicht in unserem
bestreben stoppen die unabhängigkeit zu
erreichen
in madrid dagegen nüchterne genugtuung
niemand steht über dem gesetz in einer
demokratie wie in spanien wird niemand
wegen seiner politischen ideen
verurteilt sondern wegen straftaten
er ist bisher der strafe entgangen ex
regionalpräsident karies putsch team und
er hatte sich nach belgien abgesetzt
jetzt gibt es einen neuen haftbefehl
gegen ihn
das dürfte die demonstrations-
bereitschaft der unabhängigkeits
befürworter in den nächsten tagen noch
erhöhen
die flugbegleitergewerkschaft ufo hat zu
einem warnstreik bei der lufthansa
aufgerufen
am kommenden sonntag soll das
bordpersonal in frankfurt und münchen
zwischen 6 und 11 uhr die arbeit
niederlegen
lufthansa verweigert tarifverhandlungen
mit ufo mit der begründung deren
vorstand sei nicht satzungsgemäß berufen
worden
flugausfälle will die lufthansa
vermeiden traditionsmarke made in
germany und vor jahren auch mal kult am
ende reichte das alles nicht der
hersteller für freizeitgeräte kettler
ist pleite vor allem mit dem kettcar war
das unternehmen groß geworden
generationen von kindern erkundeten mit
dem tretauto ihre welt auch sportgeräte
und fahrräder kamen aus dem hause
kettler
jetzt also das endgültige aus nach
bereits zwei insolvenzen 550 mitarbeiter
sind betroffen
der nobelpreis für
wirtschaftswissenschaften geht in diesem
jahr an drei armutsforscher aus indien
frankreich und den usa für ihren neuen
ansatz bei der weltweiten
armutsbekämpfung chip energy seine
ehefrau ist der duplo und michael krämer
zerlegten die extrem komplexe aufgabe in
vielen einzelthemen in feldversuchen
hätten sie gezeigt wie sich
beispielsweise die schulbildung und die
gesundheit von kindern mit kleinen
präzisen schritten verbessern ließen und
auch dieser preis ist sehr begehrt der
deutsche buchpreis
er wird immer am vorabend der
frankfurter buchmesse vergeben für den
besten deutschsprachigen roman seit
einer viertelstunde wissen wir welcher
titel ist dieses jahr geschafft hat es
ist der roman herkunft von sascha
stanicic ein buch über heimaten denken
klinge mit mehr ja den deutschen
buchpreis 2009 10 für den roman des
jahres verleiht die stiftung buchkultur
und leseförderung des börsenvereins des
deutschen buchhandels an sascha stanicic
riesenfreude bei einem autor der erst
mit 14 jahren hierher kam und die
deutsche sprache erlernte er schafft es
die drängende frage wo kommen wir her
wirklich in einem in bewegung geratenen
europa mit witz mit sarkasmus auch mit
traurigkeit darzustellen herkunft ist
eine autobiografie und vielem mehr
sascha stanicic besucht seine großmutter
christina in seinem kleinen bosnischen
heimatdorf
er erinnert sich an die flucht mit
seinen eltern vor dem krieg 1992 kommt
er nach deutschland ins idyllische
heidelberg einzelne geschichten ergeben
ein ganzes bruchstücke einer handlung
über allem die frage was bedeutet
herkunft und ist sie nicht zu fall zu
fall und dieser zufall pickt halt
einfach sehr extremer sollten mir war
schon klar dass das eine unveränderliche
tatsache gebot witzig bringt diese
geburt stand irgendwo statt und man ist
durch diese muss für die anderen auch
immer jemand
das ende darf der leser selbst wählen
fünf weitere romane hatten es in die
schlussrunde geschafft darunter drei
erstlingswerke sascha stanicic ist mit
41 jahren bereits fester bestandteil der
deutschen gegenwartsliteratur sehr gutes
buch kann ich nur empfehlen und nutze
die norbert und zum fußball-länderspiel
es land gegen deutschland doch schauen
wir erstmal auf das sportliche 13 0
gewonnen wenig glanz ein klassischer
arbeitssieg bei dem sich die mannschaft
von trainer löw das leben selbst schwer
gemacht hatte und zwar durch die frühe
rote karte für emrich an
in der 14 minute erst in der zweiten
halbzeit in deutschland in führung
begann mit dem doppelpack in der 51 und
dann in der 57 minute das dritte tor für
die deutsche mannschaft schoss dann timo
werner in der 71 minute
schaan und gündogan sorgten außerdem für
aufregung weil sie ein foto im internet
zunächst gelegt hatten
es zeigt spieler der türkischen
nationalmannschaft die nach ihrem sieg
über albanien salutierten lautet
türkischen fußballverband ein militär
gruß für die soldaten des landes in
syrien im spiel hatte ilkay gündogan
gefallen
der gefällt mir kommentar von ihm und
emre chan zum militär salut des
befreundeten türkischen nationalspieler
cenk tosun hatte da bereits wie 2018 der
besuch beim türkischen präsidenten
erdogan mit mesut özil für wirbel
gesorgt
eine bestimmte partei macht es doch des
öfteren ich kann noch mal betonen dass
da keine politische absicht hinter war
dfb direktor oliver bierhoff stellte
inzwischen mit blick auf gündogan und
scheint klar
sie wissen auch dass es ein fehler war
wir müssen weiterhin daran arbeiten die
sinne unserer spieler gerade für den
umgang in den sozialen netzwerken zu
schärfen
da darf es keinen spielraum für
interpretationen geben das am morgen
veröffentlichte foto der mannschaft mit
dem statement gegen jede form von gewalt
sollte das zum ausdruck bringen
die kenianerin bridget cosgrave hat den
16 jahre alten marathon weltrekord der
britin paula radcliffe gebrauchen
die 25-jährige gewann gestern in chicago
im zwei stunden 14 minuten und vier
sekunden
damit verbesserte costa ihren april in
london aufgestellte persönliche
bestmarke um über 4 minuten
tolle leistung
der goldene oktober hält im osten noch
durch von besten zieht dagegen regen auf
mehr zum wetter gleich von katja honnef
das war es von uns christian sievers
erwartet sie um 21 uhr 45 im
heute-journal und hier freut sich morgen
barbara hahlweg auf sie wir danken für
ihr interesse
wünschen noch einen entspannten abend
und sagen tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
gestern war es so warm wie noch nie in
deutschland mitte oktober mit 27,8 grad
im südwesten
und auch heute wo das noch mal ähnlich
war mit 26 27 grad besonders wieder im
südwesten deutschlands und so ist es
auch kein wunder dass ist in der nacht
recht mild bleibt am niederrhein mit 16
grad in bayern sinken die temperaturen
dagegen auf sechs oder fünf grad und
dort bild sich zum teil dicker nebel an
der nordseeküste gibt es noch etwas
regen und morgen kommen dann dichtere
wolken von westen heran
die bringen schon am vormittag den
ersten regen westlich des rheins im
osten bleibt es dagegen noch mal bei
einem schönen oktobertag nur nicht an
der unteren donau
da hält sich der nebel zum teil c am
nachmittag kommen dann die regenwolken
rauch an der weser im sauerland und im
schwarzwald an und es kann noch einzelne
gewitter dabei sein
im osten bleibt es dagegen trocken die
höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen 17 grad an der ostsee und auch
unter den regenwolken im westen und 26
grad an der elbe in den nächsten tagen
beschränken sich die regenwolken im
wesentlichen auf den norden im süden
wird es sonnig und mild schön ab noch